very good morning a review into scottish
cricket has found it to be
institutionally racist and with some
cases now being referred to the police
the independent investigation was
launched after two scotland players
claimed they had suffered racial abuse
the findings of the review which had
been seen by sky news are due to be
published on monday let's speak to our
scotland correspondent james matthews
james this is just another blow for
cricket after it's been trying to
recover after the yorkshire racism
scandal
yeah it's certainly a blow for scottish
cricket the events in scotland come in
the wake of circumstances
in yorkshire and issues of racism were
raised by
majid hack scotland's leading wicket
taker and kasim sheikh a 27 times
capped batsman they gave interviews to
sky sports in which they claimed
of abuse throughout their careers saying
that they had been treated differently
from white colleagues throughout the
sport now this review will be published
on monday i can tell you that we have
learned it very much backs up the
central claim that was originally made
of institutional racism that runs
through cricket scotland the sports
organizing body one source telling us
institutional racism was the claim at
the start of this and that's very much
backed up by what investigators have
found multiple referrals have been made
to a variety of organizations about
alleged racist behavior and it's a
police matter too because one of those
referrals at least one has been made to
police scotland with a view to further
investigations so on monday the full
findings will be made public there will
undoubtedly be consequences for cricket
scotland perhaps for their board members
sports scotland the organizing body of
sport north of the border has said it
wants to see
the recommendations enacted in full
but
while we wait for those full revelations
on monday
let's speak to one of the cricketers at
the center of this affair in scotland
kassim sheikh batsman 27 times capped
for your country casum
this started in scotland with you with
yourself and magic going public about
your experiences
uh within cricket
tell me about the racism that you
experienced
i think um it all started obviously when
nazim rafiq
spoke out south of the border
and then we were asked questions
in scotland of what we felt
and what we felt was you know we were
always treated
differently
you just have to look at kind of the
stats quite easily to
compare how many minorities have played
for the national team and we were we
were lucky to make it to that point but
you know stumbled and didn't play after
speaking out against a coach at the time
so over reaction magic sent a tweet in
2015 sent home from the world cup never
to play for his country again i never
played again
these type of overreactions uh suggest
to me that we're treated differently
because of of the color of our skin
compared to to white counterparts which
i don't feel they face the same thing
in terms of participation in cricket um
we're at the edinburgh south club here
at inch in edinburgh
there is huge participation
among south asians
at this level but relatively few at the
top level
we had this conversation before we went
before we went on and i said have a look
around this is just one one small
cricket club in scotland and what 90
percent of the the kids here are
probably from south asian minority
backgrounds um it's the same across the
country so yes why doesn't add up you
know a national team level i'm not
suggesting we have quota systems or
anything like that not at all i just
wanted to see equal opportunities
and people from minorities have got a
south asian background in particular
crickets in the blood um i would like to
see more of them coming through and
playing at national team level there is
reasonable representation at junior
level but it's the jump from there to
national level that seems that just
doesn't add up for me and you believe
that racism cut your cricket career
short
yes i do believe the overreaction i i
publicly apologized as well i did
you know a journalist was chosen for me
to speak to to apologize i did the
apology and the the article was titled
shake it's humble pie um did i ever play
for my country again no so
yes i do think race was part of that
reason tell me about the impact on
yourself your family your life
yeah playing for scotland was was
everything to me um i traveled the world
to better myself as a player i played
from the age of 12 for scotland um all
through the age groups when i got to
national team level it just didn't seem
to i didn't seem to set to get
comfortable there at any point or feel i
had the same opportunities as others
it's affected my affected my my mental
health i was definitely going through
depression for the two three years after
playing um this will probably never
leave me i'm not going to go back in a
cricket pitch for scotland again so i'll
probably be thinking about this for for
the rest of my days that i had
unfinished business
but coming on 38 now what's important to
me is that the next generation current
generation are treated fairly and equal
opportunities are given you've not told
us details of what's in this report
that's something we've learned elsewhere
but following publication on monday what
chains do you want to see made
i want to see more participation
from the minorities
at board level um administration
administrators coaches players
for me it's top to bottom and even
cricket clubs as well i feel like having
minorities involved and their um and
their boards etc and their committees
i'd like to see more people
getting involved and uh yeah definitely
participation higher numbers is
important very much so who would you
blame or what would you believe is it
the structure overall or individuals
concerned
within qriket scotland i think a lot of
the buck falls with the leaders you know
boardroom level these are the one people
that really need to answer the question
they're the ones that should be
setting the right
tone and cricket and that should be
filtering through all the way down to
grassroots so yes i think um the the
board level is where the questions need
to be asked
thanks very much indeed for joining us
cassie your captain of edinburgh south
these days yeah no i'm player coach
player coach uh pretty much like
captaincy uh we've got a big game today
and tomorrow against the same team so
yeah
nice to
nice to looking for hopefully the rain
stays off your colleague tells me
there's going to be some rain in the air
good luck with that thank you thanks for
watching dude for your time uh cassie
shane one of the the two individuals at
the heart of this matter qriket scotland
have issued a statement and i'll read it
to you they have said in response to our
reporting cricket should be a welcoming
place for everyone and not some whether
racism or any form of discrimination
takes place
the cricket scotland board they say is
truly sorry to everyone who has
experienced racism and cricket in
scotland they go on to say we would like
to sincerely thank everyone who's been
involved in contributing to the review
however the board is not in a position
to comment on the independent reviews
report as we will not see it until it's
published publicly
on monday the statement from qriket
scotland